-Welcome back to the show.
-Thanks for having me, man.
-I'm always happy to see you.
You look great, by the way.
How you been?
-I'm alright.
I got married in COVID.
-Oh, congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I -- So I've decided to
let myself go, you know?
-Why?
-Well, hey, look,
I've been taking pills
to keep the hair on my head
for 15 years now, right?
And I've got crap hair.
I've spent tens of thousands
of dollars
on this really rubbish hair.
And I take these pills every day
to keep it in.
But because I take the pills,
it makes downstairs
not work anymore, right?
So I have to take
a blue pill to counteract
the brown pill
to make everything work.
So, I've got two options
in life, right?
I've got either "I keep my hair
and I can't have
sex with anyone,"
or "I lose my hair and no one
wants to have sex with me."
But --
-That's a conundrum.
-So, now I've got the wife,
I just,
"Alright, I'm going to
lose the hair.
-Yeah.
-But it's hard going bald.
People pick on the --
We live in a society where
we're not allowed to
fat-shame anymore, right?
And I agree with that.
We shouldn't fat-shame.
But we bald-shame all the time.
-Yeah.
-If a man loses his hair,
you got, "Good day, baldy."
In Britain, the slang term for a
bald person is "slaphead."
Right? Like, they actually
threaten violence against you.
And no one chooses to go bald.
Any man who's gone ba--
And you're not allowed to
cover it up.
Heaven forbid a man tries
to cover up his baldness
and grows a bit out here
and whips it across.
That person is a loser.
Or if they a wear a wig,
they're banished
from our society.
If you wear a wig
and you leave any party,
everyone is talking about your
wig after you leave the party.
-That is true.
-You're not allowed to --
Yet, women are allowed to
wear a wig over their
full head of hair,
and they're just having
a bit of fun.
-Yeah.
-Do you know how
offensive that is?
Look, I've done everything, man.
I've done the transplants.
This is all not real.
I've had to move the hair
from here to here.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, look,
even now with the lights,
I've got to put
special powder in me hair
so you can't see
my scalp, because,
you know,
all that stuff floats up.
It's -- Look, the transplant's
a good thing, right?
A lot of people take
the transplant.
Biden's had the transplant.
-Yes.
-If you look at those
old footage of him when he's 30
and now look at him at 100,
it's completely different.
-I want to talk about --
I want to talk about
your tour and
specifically the name.
Well, it's called
"The Moist Tour."
How? Why?
-Well, when you
get asked to name a tour,
it's one of these things like
your agents ring you up
and go, "What's the name
of the tour?
You haven't written
the jokes yet.
So, I basically just Googled,
"What's the most offensive word
that isn't a swear word?"
And it turns out "moist"
is number 1.
So if you come to the show,
don't worry.
You're not gonna
get wet or anything,
unless you find me handsome.
-Yeah.
Geez. Unbelievable.
Don't laugh at that.
Come on, don't support --
don't support it.
Wait. So, tomorrow,
you're in San Antonio, Texas.
And then you're in
Sugar Land on Saturday.
But you're going
all over the place.
You're going to Michigan.
You're going to Canada.
-I follow the winters.
They send me -- Anywhere
that winter is happening,
they reckon they sell more.
-You're going to
Australia, eventually.
-Yeah.
-And I know you have a very --
You have a good photo
that you brought us.
You went to Vegas
and you actually hung out with
the Thunder From Down Under.
-I went to the
Thunder From Down Under, yeah.
I was writing a sitcom
back in the day
about me being a male stripper.
And TBS bought the script,
but, somehow,
it never made it to TV.
-Wow.
-And, so, I went to see
the Thunder From Down Under.
I got to give it up
for Australians, though.
We got any Australians?
[ Light cheering ]
Yeah, I've got to give it up
to the Australians.
It's like we can market
that we're sexy, you know?
The Thunder From Down Under,
and girls go,
"Oh, a few Australian blokes.
That'll be alright."
You couldn't do that
with anyone else.
You couldn't go,
"Oh, we have the Canadian boys,
the Maple Syrup Kids.
They're gonna go --"
You know?
We've got some
Scottish blokes in kilts.
That should sell some tickets.
-Yeah.
-You know, but I went along,
and after the show,
what they do is,
they take photos.
All the girls
that are in the show --
they come and sit on
the lap of the members from
the Thunder From Down Under
and they take a photo that
they can take home with them.
And I stood in the back
for all the photos,
and no one noticed I was there.
I wonder if you can
see me in the pic.
-Alright, let's see
if you can find Jim Jefferies
in this picture of
the Thunder From Down Under.
There's a...
[ Laughter ]
Dude, you are the best.
And no one said anything to you?
-No, no, no.
-You're the palest guy --
-I'm the least-tan person that's
ever come out of Australia.
-This is the
funniest picture, man.
Jim Jefferies,
I always love when you come by.
Congrats on the baby
and your wife.
You know I love you.
Jim Jefferies.
For tickets to "The Moist Tour,"
go to jimjefferies.com.